قتل زلزال في تركيا الى
31,643 في اخر تحديث كان 29000 الان يتخطى
وهذا ما كان اشار اليه اكثر من مسؤول من
توقعات بان الارقام ستزيد بشكل كبير خلال
هذه الايام بعد ان توقف انتشال الاحياء في
كثير من الاماكن على العموم سلام خضر التي
كانت تتابع في ديار بكر ما كان يحصل
وقدم التقرير مفصل عن الاجواء هناك هي
الان موجوده في بلده اديمان وستتابع معنا
ايضا الاجواء هناك وكذلك من جندريس فيري
في حلب معنى مراسلنا عمرو حلبي وايضا من
داخل اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه افاد
في انقره تنضم الينا فرح الزمان شوقي فرح
اذا الحصيله ترتفع كنت قلت ايضا في
الرساله السابقه بان تركيا امام الان اكبر
حصيله ضحايا زلزال في تاريخها نقترب من
تخطي هذا الرقم صحيح
بدنا قريبين للغايه للوصول الى حصيله اكبر
زلزال الذي وقع في عام 1939
نحن نقترب الان من رقم 32 الفا وانت
تخطينا هذا الرقم سيصبح هذا الزلزال هو
الاضخم والاكبر في في القرن
وعلى الاغلب يعني في في تاريخنا المعاصر
ايضا بحسب بيان الافاد الذي ورد الان نحن
نتحدث عن
31,643 قتيلا
الحديث عن هزات ارتداديه رقم اكبر في
الحقيقه بدنا نتحدث عن تجاوز الرقم ل 2700
هزه هذا يعني 300 هزه جديده على الرقم
الذي اعلن عنه يوم امس وهو في الحقيقه
بحسب ما يقول الخبراء هنا في افاد بانه
معدل كبير للغايه يدور الحديث عن
200 واعتقد الف شخص على الارض يقومون
باعمال الانقاذ الان هذا الرقم ايضا ارتفع
رغم مروري ثمانيه ايام على وقوع هذا
الزلزال وهو ما يعني بان الاعمال يجب ان
تستمر وستستمر في الساعات المقبله يعني
هنالك كثافه في الحركه وفي ارسال المزيد
من طواقم الانقاذ افات تتحدث عن المزيد من
التعيينات بالنسبه للاولى والمحافظين
تخصيص سفراء من الخارجيه التركيه كل هؤلاء
ليتابعوا الامور على
الارض بالتالي هنالك تكليفات ايضا جديده
وهذا الامر على ما اعتقد يرتبط كذلك
باعلان الحكومه او اعلان الرئيس التركي عن
حاله الطوارئ في تلك
المناطق بكل الاحوال هنالك اعداد اكبر من
المناطق التي تم اجلاء المواطنين منها هذا
يعني تفريغ او تخليه تلك المناطق من
ساكنيها وهذا بطبيعه الحال ايضا
في التركيز اكثر على الاعمال المستمره
والدائره هناك بكل الاحوال الحكومه التي
كانت قد تحدثت عن سقف زمني لاعاده الاعمار
هو سنه تتحدث كذلك عن معاينه عدد اكبر من
المباني عدد باتي يتخطى 200 الف افات تقول
بانها ارسلت ما يقارب 1300 فريق مسؤوليه
هؤلاء هي معاينه المباني تقديم تقارير
ميدانيه حولها بالتالي سيكون سنكون امام
اعداد اكبر
عدد العدد الذي تجاوز 8000 في وقت سابق
للابنيه المدمره بالكامل بحسب التوقعات
وبحسب هذه الارقام سنكون امام اعداد اكبر
في المرحله
المقبله بالنسبه الى هنالك على جانب ثاني
القضيه التي باتت
تتجه الى الواجهه اكثر فاكثر قضيه
الاعتقالات اليوم مديريه تتحدث عن ملف
جديد الا وهو ملف وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تم توقيف واعتقال اشخاص تتهمهم الحكومه
بنشر انباء واخبار يصفونها بانها تزيد
الامور سوءا هذا الامر هي محاوله لضبط
الامور بسبب نشر شائعات او نشر انباء كان
لها الاثر السيء بطبيعه الحال على
المواطنين بحسب ما تقوله الحكومه نحن
نتحدث عن توقيفات نتحدث عن اعتقالات تتعلق
بملف وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لكن على
جانب ثاني هنالك الاعتقالات المتعلقه
بملفات السرقه الى جانب الملفات المرتبطه
بالابنيه المهدمه مقاولون متعهدوا بناء
كلهم الان تحت المراقبه وهنالك منع سفر
لعديدين منهم ليلى اشكرك